leisurely bicycle outings are not Demi
McCaskill's thing the Scottish trials
biker tracks down unusual shortcuts for
me that my favorite thing about trials
biking is the freedom to do whatever you
want when I go out riding in the city
I'm always looking at the walls the
rails you know curbs everything as I as
a giant place to serve ride my bike even
the most rugged terrain is no obstacle
for him in his most recent video called
the ridge he surmounted a 1,000 meter
peak on the Scottish island of Skye
Danny MacAskill is at home here on the
Inner Hebrides most challenging things I
did in the ridge film was probably
trying to gap between two boulders um I
mean it wasn't particularly a big gap or
a particularly big drop but it was onto
an upslope and I was finding it very
difficult to land the trick and
radiative shots making the film
fulfilled McCaskill's dream of scaling a
local peak on a bike
we're very lucky with that you know it's
I don't never forget being on top of
that you know the pinnacle it all
started with this amateur video that
displays McCaskill's bicycling art his
roommate David solar be shopped and
edited and posted a clip on the Internet
in April 2009 within 40 hours the post
had been seen 350,000 times since then
the short clip has been viewed 36
million times even professional cyclist
Lance Armstrong was fascinated and he
encouraged people to watch the video
Danny MacAskill has lived in Glasgow for
two years now his videos have made him a
star and not just on the Internet
nowadays people recognize him on the
street they want to take photographs of
him for the kids
the revolutionised bike in world higher
than it's ever been because he's
bringing new tricks and new ways to it
McCaskill still surprised at his
popularity when I was younger I never
had a goal to be a professional writer
you know and I really find my situation
now very surreal you know I kind of made
this first main video just for fun with
my friend and I never really quite
realized what impact that would have
trials biking has been around since the
1970s McCaskill has been practicing
since he was four years old and he works
on some tricks for years before he
perfects them spills and injuries are
part of the job
definitely had a number of broken bones
over the years I mean countless ones
really bad I mean I just I don't even
look at it as a setback at all it's just
a case of healing up and then getting
back onto the bike
after the great success of his first
video companies like Red Bulls signed
him to a contract now he can devote
himself entirely to his sport in
Edinburgh and other parts of Scotland he
shot the clip called way back home it's
now been viewed 34 million times
while shooting this video
Danny injured himself so seriously that
he was in the hospital for months but
afterward he finished the film the
Manute leap land films always tell
little stories one called imaginate is
about a young boy's dreams I think it's
very important that you have like some
kind of theme I mean often it's like a
story or a star journey you know you're
awfully often stopped traveling from A
to B and I think that makes a big
difference McCaskill usually comes up
with the stories and scouts out the
locations himself he gets his ideas from
talking with friends he also talks with
them about his future writing the trials
by it's quite physically demanding and I
know I can't do it forever
you know I'll certainly try my best to
be three writing for the next four years
and as long as he can ride he'll keep
making these creative clips like this
one in a flood ravaged town in Argentina
Danny MacAskill is thinking about
putting together an entire bicycle show
until then fans can enjoy his cycling
skill on the Internet